black lives matter Teeters on the brink
of insolvency after an 8.5 million
dollar loss in 2022. you know they made
something like I think 77 million
dollars in 2021 or something like that
so blm's during solvency in food racism
stock is going to be through the roof
yeah yeah they uh only raised 9.3
million in 2022 down from 77 million and
21 and 90 million in 2020. they're going
to spend the next year that is a massive
collapse you're going to spend the next
year uh advocating Donald Trump to get
the uh to get the race the racism up
they say uh Patrice Culler resigned as
executive director in May 2021 did the
public learned she spent 3.2 million on
four separate homes on top of other
lavish expenses prior to a resignation
she was accused of funneling 230
thousand dollars to a company that
belonged to the father of her child well
there's a bunch of nepotism going on in
here but uh hey man look this is this is
good news right people aren't donating
anymore this is a lot moving into a 2024
election cycle
if they had 90 million in 2020 and then
two years later they're down to they're
down by 90 percent
that means the sentiment among regular
people is not favorable for black lives
matter and it means that many of these
people may be waking up or may just be
like we're out of this we're not going
to be involved in Corporate America
right because they got a lot from
Corporate America
which is really important in in this
case is like the the flip around on this
with corporate America is really
important for the future of the country
and and maybe maybe there's some hope
there I don't have a lot of Hope for
Corporate America but maybe there's a
little bit of things like ESG so there
was difficult there's the spirit if we
pull this up on Civics you can see that
around uh in 2019 there was a flip the
majority of people now started to
support black lives matter after uh
George Floyd died at spite at 52 percent
but now
43 oppose 41 support
and among independent voters
45 oppose and it seems relatively stable
but it spiked a great deal and that's
the riots
the rioting made independent voters say
you know what I do not support this
group which is really great news for the
Republicans how many people lied because
they were afraid they'd be called racist
for saying they don't support black
lives matter yep do you know the history
of black lives matter where it came from
Trayvon Martin
so yeah when it actually got its start
with student government in Missouri
so when the whole thing happened in
Missouri way back what thing in Missouri
Ferguson Ferguson all right and there
was a student government a student body
president here's a young black man uh
they started a campaign basically using
student government funds it was just
like because they have slush funds at
all these big universities and that's
where the the name black lives matter
came from uh it started well before that
and he got picked up by yeah black lives
matter started with Trayvon Martin
protests in New York City I think pretty
sure so the the Ferguson stuff was a
couple years later but they but they
basically turned it into like a a
movement that they funded across all of
the different universities the student
governments and then that ended that kid
in this white house with Barack Obama
his name was Peyton head when did
Patrice get involved This was later so
then they formalized that as an
organization but it's still the the tiny
legs that it had were funded essentially
through Student Government which was a
really interesting
tidbit which is a really important
reason why you can't let these
these universities just kind of run
rampant with this thing
yeah I remember in 20 roughly 2013 when
I first heard it 2014 when I first heard
it it was definitely Trayvon Martin at
least that's what gave it legs on the
Nationals yeah it started July 2013 with
the use of the hashtag black lives
matter on social media after the
acquittal of George Zimmerman yeah
because I remember I was down there in
New York when I was covering those
protests when all that went down and
that was the uh that was the beginning
and then there was some other guy who
created something called black lives
matter I think before all of them and
they they like shut his hijacked at all
yeah they stole it from him but uh but
they put but the money that got behind
it was originally from just like they
latched on to it identified it and said
this is something and so they took a
bunch of student government money which
is they were able to do across the
country landed at the White House
solidified it
I think we're Democrats there like oh we
can get votes from this totally let's
play that game this is this is a lot
about the current state of of politics
in this country though if BLM is
officially not in anymore
they're not people aren't donating so
that's it we're gonna we're gonna be
moving into a new era I think I'm fairly
optimistic especially with shows like
this on the rise with uh I mean look at
Tucker Carlson goes um independent
launching his own network or his own
online channels the rise of Rumble Elon
Musk buying Twitter I think it's all
looking fairly positive yeah they can't
shut things down last minute on us yeah
it's cool yeah there's hope yep no I
mean it's it's sitting you have to be
remarkably financially irresponsible to
mess a grift like that up you are the
face of give me money if you're Against
Racism anyone in Corporate America who
wants to be seen as virtuously
contributing to the anti-racist cause
has to give money to me how did you go
broke how how did you go broke well they
were spending a lot of questionable sums
of money yeah exactly hiring family
members
their cause is a scam anyway yep well
exactly right because there's never
going to be any end point for them
Patrice at what point I got maybe come
on at what point was BLM going to say
all right we solved racism
by that statement anyway I am saying the
idea that is per that is perpetrated uh
that there you know what did that kid
say 30 of black people are killed every
year yeah these ideas of this Mass
systemic inequality is just completely
untrue is there racism yes is there
racism in government there is are there
racist people yes there are to the
degree that they've brought it up it's
not true George Zimmerman was a Hispanic
Hispanic guy so this whole idea is
launched off of this
idea of of racism from white people and
it's like you mean when that Hispanic
guy fought with that kid like what are
you talking about yeah or when Michael
Brown it's confirmed by the the Eric
Holder AG that he did not have his hands
up and fought the cop
like we get it man you know like we
don't want innocent people dying
especially based on race but the the pr
the premise of what you're donating to
doesn't make sense but hey I don't know
what they do with it they're getting
they're getting because they
bought this big house yeah but if they
bought a house to do a studio or
something what are you going to complain
about I don't think anybody who donated
to BLM is crying about it right now one
some people maybe but most people are
probably fine they don't let it donated
1.5 million dollars went to patrice's
Brother for security yeah well I think
for security and then you got to ask and
so there are there are questions about
they said they didn't want to do
traditional security or police because
the distrust around policing but people
think these sums of money means he wrote
a check for a two million like a million
and a half bucks to a guy and then he
bought it for Ferrari no no this could
have been licensing equipment Staffing
right so she also gave a guy 970 000 for
Live Events or the organization gave
Live Events and everyone's like oh that
dude probably didn't see that money
right organizing Live Events is very
very expensive offensive I just want to
mention something because Tim you said
that you know the people who donated to
BLM probably aren't too upset I just
want to let everyone in this room know
that we've all donated to BLM because JB
pritzker gave 300 000 in federal covid
relief money to BLM well I mean if you
live here but no it was Federal covid
relief money right right yeah from the
federal government they said and and
pritzker said you know what you know how
we're going to relieve people of covet
giving money to BLM okay thank you I can
tell you at Turning Point running a
large non-profit that you know we have a
very blessed to raise a lot of money
we've hired and Staffing we've staffed
thousands of people over the years right
like we have right now on staff hundreds
and hundreds of people between our
organization
building that within a year you know
where did all that money go is a really
great question because I mean we're not
talking about 10 million dollars we're
not talking about 15 million we're
talking about literally they were and
they had transactionally hundreds of
millions of dollars that they had access
to essentially in in capital that they
worked with
where did all the money go
that's a great question right because
they didn't where all the staff where's
the BLM staff I know what it costs to
put on a massive live event I know what
it cost to put on these huge things they
didn't do any of that so you know what
we know of is just a very small sliver
of what really bad things they probably
did actually happen because you don't
know these things when C3 C4s they file
this thing I don't even I'm not even
convinced BLM did anything untoward in a
certain sense you give them money they
can do what they want with they just
couldn't build there's no way you can
build a 100 million dollar organization
in basically a year or two years they've
been around what they had to do but I
mean they they the same people were
involved since 2013. right but they they
but they built the actual organization
within like a year after getting all
that money because they were taking they
were just taking in money based off of
the news and the climate and from
Corporate America like they just didn't
have the capability of actually building
this thing so it's not a surprise that
they've completely failed
yeah no but I think that the important
takeaway as I mentioned earlier is
whatever it is that's resulting in
people not wanting to give BLM money is
going to have a similar rollover effect
on everything else yeah and I think
there's a lot of people who are wising
up you know we were skating in uh in
Hagerstown I mentioned this the other
day and a bunch of local Suburban
Maryland people were like yo crime is
getting out of control what's going on
and then these people started talking
about gun ownership gun rights and I'm
like there it is 2A is going to be
stronger Trump's going to win and it's
because these suburbanite people are
tied to the violent crime and the cops
doing nothing about it yeah what do you
do though right if your neighborhood is
falling to crap eventually you have
nothing to do but just to ask that
question
yep
and then you end up voting for the right
guy
all roads lead to the same place when
you're you know when you have a action
the constitutional principles being
followed that's probably the reason why
they want to destroy all of it that's
why they want to subvert all this with
you know crazy stuff like you know I saw
some things on National popular vote not
to take us off but ranked Choice voting
this stuff is really scary because no
matter what the public sentiment is
they're trying to subvert whatever that
is that's that's the future that's what
we're up against thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time